Oh
fifteen you have compromised
to be on site one how copy Roger that
[Music]
with ready or not void interactive aims
to explore what it's like to be an
officer in the elite special weapons and
tactics unit also known as SWAT inspired
by real-world events the game is a blend
of first-person action and tactical
strategy wrapped in a unique detailed
and twisted for simile of a modern
United States ready or not sufficient of
America is downtrodden cruel and corrupt
you're given the difficult task of
bringing some semblance of order to a
city divided by crime across a
single-player story team up with friends
to take down suspects in a cooperative
mode or battle a rogue movement in PvP
you're placed in the boots of an officer
in the cities want a unit equipped with
military hardware tasked with protection
taking on high-risk situations and
bringing order to chaos in ready or not
you will encounter a wide array of
unique characters all with their own
stories that contribute to the narrative
thread from kingpin drug dealers to beat
cops to schoolchildren
[Music]
collaborating with law enforcement void
Interactive's goal is to create an
authentic and accurate tactical
experience with ready or not you and
your team are able to customize their
personnel gear and weaponry to
appropriately fit each missions
objectives armor can be customized to
suit your playstyle and with bullet
mapped interactions the right selection
may be imperative to survival where
other titles only allow you to kill
enemies ready or not attempts to
challenge how you handle combat with a
rule based emphasis on less lethal and
safe takedown
good I'll drop it you only say yeah
we're gonna be detained for long however
with an abundance of non-lethal
alternatives such as beanbag shotguns
tasers and flash bangs coercing targets
into surrendering has never been easier
levels come with situations that require
solving each scenario is intelligently
randomized including target locations
suspect protection traps and more
provided within the game is a wide array
of tools to assist your SWAT team in
navigating and securing the environment
as well as apprehending and combating
suspects players can create their own
strategies during the mission planning
phase for example knock out the power
and slip in under the cover of darkness
use tactical ladders and door ramps to
access places beyond your reach
command marksman to take shots at your
word with the sniper unit load up on CS
gas and breach rooms in a white haze or
get behind a tactical shield for a less
bullet prone approach all options are
available to you when choosing a loadout
best fit for your team every decision is
yours
to carry into each mission
[Music]
[Music]
talk reporting entry team you're cleared
to make entry at when Lee guest entrance
use the wand check for targets okay
mayor gun ready there's a lot of them if
they all have guns
ready or not aims to truly ground the
player in its world attention has been
put into every facet of the player
controller ensuring an immersive
tactical first-person experience with an
unprecedented level of depth and players
can lean variably in an incrementally
change speed on-the-fly entry points
like doors can be interacted with in
many ways players may open them
regularly kick them in or incrementally
swing them open in order to insert a
grenade or engage a target a stealthy
SWAT team may lockpick doors in the way
while a more aggressive unit may use a
breaching shotgun to gain access but be
careful some suspects may booby trap
doors with alarm systems explosives or
other objects
the world of ready or not is unforgiving
and brutal by Nature
it features both open maneuverable areas
and claustrophobic spaces where one
wrong move could make all the difference
while players command their own unit of
operators there's always someone higher
in the chain of command looking for
answers report everything to Talk
Tactical Operations Command the
directive unit tracking your progress
utilizing integrity and patience in your
mission will balance the odds of success
chaos is dictated by the suspects and
civilians unpredictable nature during
each mission tension and emotions for
them will be high so sometimes plans can
go awry projectile types and velocity
simulation put a spin on the already
raised stakes bullets will penetrate
through surfaces based on thickness
material and speed
ready or not will accommodate a career
mode where the player must orchestrate
plans with an AI driven SWAT team under
their command the game also includes a
fierce tactical PvP environment where
the Metro SWAT team will be faced
against a rogue movement hell-bent on
bringing the city to its knees
void Interactive has aimed to cover all
areas of gameplay by offering a fiercely
competitive and entertaining set of
multiplayer modes but we will go into
more detail at a later date void will
aim to support the players in as many
ways as possible which includes the
ability for you to host your own
dedicated servers or modify the game in
order to add new weapons textures
characters levels and more ready or not
is now available for pre-order through
voids website
[Music]
you